how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the falcon and the winter soldier
reintroduced sharon carter to the mcu
however by the end of the series we
found out that this wasn't exactly the
same sharon carter that we knew from
before and that's what we're going to be
talking about
in this video and how it could actually
mean something
very very big and a big thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
squarespace is an all-in-one platform
for you to create a website and online
store they provide marketing tools and
analytics and everything that you need
to create a beautiful online presence
and run your business
more in them in just a bit the last time
we saw her was in captain america civil
war where she was actually helping out
steve rogers
sam and bucky and the last time we left
her in captain america civil war yes she
was helping out steve and that was kind
of breaking the rules
she loved her job working for the
government working to make
the world a better place now ultimately
she believed that steve was doing
something for good so she didn't mind
helping him out and getting into some
trouble for it but that sharon carter
that we left off with in captain america
civil war
is very very different than the one that
we had in the falcon and the winter
soldier
and big spoiler alert if you have not
seen the ending or the post credit scene
of the falcon and the winter soldier
you've been warned spoilers coming in
the post credit scene of the falcon and
the winter soldier finale we learned
that sharon carter was
indeed the power broker which kind of
came as
a surprise on many many different levels
and one of the reasons why it was such a
big surprise is because sharon carter
was a really really good person
dedicated to serving her country she was
following in the footsteps of her aunt
peggy carter who was an absolute hero to
her she
looked up to her a lot which is why some
things don't really make sense
there are some things that aren't
necessarily lining up which leads me to
believe that
sharon carter could actually be a scroll
that's right i don't think that this is
the real sharon carter and i think there
were a few clues along the way
in the falcon and the winter soldier
series pointing towards sharon carter in
the falcon and the winter soldier being
a scroll
and i'll explain everything in this
video including who
sharon might have been calling in that
post-credits scene and where the real
sharon carter might have been through
this entire time
if we take a look at sharon carter's
role as the power broker we see a few
hints leading us towards the fact that
she could be a scroll
throughout the show we are led to
believe that the power broker is a huge
player in magipore and the power broker
or
sharon is it seems like the power broker
essentially runs madrid
and as we're in magipor it seems like
everybody knows who the power broker is
but here's something odd if the power
broker is so big
and well known and also very powerful
then why did people
attack sharon at the docks people came
after sam and bucky and zemo when they
were going after dr nagel and they
attacked
sharon why it's very clear throughout a
few episodes that sharon does talk to
people and mingle with people she's the
power broker she has a lot of
connections so
shouldn't these people attacking her
know who she is weren't they
actually sent by the power broker aka
her
well one explanation is she might not
have a true
form if sharon is indeed a skrull then
this scroll could shapeshift into other
people as well
making the power brokers organization
seem a lot bigger than it actually is
this would explain why these attackers
actually attacked her
not knowing that she was the power
broker further proof is that
zemo who apparently knows everyone in
magipore
doesn't know the power broker and that's
rather odd as he walks into majorpoor he
seemingly knows everybody that he talks
to and he says that he knows
of the power broker but has never seen
the power broker's face how is he so
connected to everyone that is connected
to the power broker but not the actual
power broker
this could also be because sharon carter
can shapeshift
another thing to mention that is kind of
odd is that only two years went by
between
civil war and infinity war in civil war
sharon got steve shield and falcon's
wings
making her an enemy of the state and
then she apparently went on the run
and started her journey as the power
broker that's not a lot of time that
went by
now she built up this giant empire in
two years
kudos to her but let's not forget that
sharon carter was snapped
she was one of the victims that got
dusted this was confirmed in avengers
in-game where they were looking at the
monitor that showed all of the dusted
victims
so if she did indeed build an empire
within these two years
she was gone for five years after that
and to still have an
empire five years later when she was
gone for that entire time
doesn't really make sense especially if
you consider the fact that sharon carter
as the power broker was helping carly
and carly and her group of people were
around during the snap
they existed during that five-year
period because that's when they believed
that life was
actually better now the falcon and the
winter soldier takes place
six months after avengers end game where
everybody came back
six months is not really enough time to
build an empire so how could sharon
carter be helping the flag smashers if
she wasn't around during the blip
during those 5 years where everybody was
gone this is another reason why i
believe her to be a scroll
i think sharon carter actually was
dusted and a scroll took her place
and the reason why any of the avengers
couldn't find her because the scroll
anytime they got by would shapeshift
into a different person
that is if any of the avengers actually
did decide to look for her
but i believe that it was a skrull who
built this empire up during this
five-year period of time
pretending and actually taking on the
identity of sharon carter
and this could actually explain the post
credit scene of the falcon in the winter
soldier finale
in the post-credits scene sharon calls
somebody and tells them to get their
buyers ready
she says that super soldiers may be off
the menu but they're about to have
access to government secrets
prototype weapons and more now if sharon
is indeed a scroll
an alien this could actually be a call
to the alien mothership
because it's already been confirmed and
announced that marvel is making a secret
invasion
disney plus show this is where the
scroll actually invade
earth disguised as other heroes in fact
in the comics it's revealed that
actually half of the heroes that
everybody has known and love have been
scrolls for a pretty long time and
what's the best way to invade a planet
learn about their strengths and
weaknesses and infiltrate from the
inside
then also try to have an army whether
that be super soldiers or
other armies fighting for you you're
going to want to be equipped to take
over the world essentially and
eventually go up against some avengers
now why does it make sense that she is a
scroll well it actually makes more sense
for her to be a scroll than it does for
her not to be
again the sharing that we saw in the
falcon and the winter soldier is so
different than the one that we have
known in the mcu just think about this
for a second
sharon carter was the niece of peggy
carter and she absolutely loved her and
adored her
she's the reason that she went into her
field started working for shield and
then the cia and she taught her to be
true to herself
just listen to how peggy affected and
impacted sharon by how she talks about
her in her eulogy for her in civil war
even if everyone is telling you that
something wrong
is something right even if the whole
world is telling you to move
it is your duty to plant yourself like a
tree
look them in the eye and say no you move
it doesn't seem like sharon would just
betray all of her values and her country
she knew what she was doing by helping
steve in civil war she knew they'd come
after her this all doesn't add up to a
person who would betray her country on a
huge level which is why i really do
think a good explanation for this
is the fact that she could be a scroll
setting up secret invasion
but if this is true of course the real
question is now
where is the real sharon and of course
i'll answer this and again a big thank
you to squarespace for sponsoring this
video if you are looking to build an
online presence and start a website or
an online store squarespace makes it
super simple for you
they offer custom templates that you can
choose and simply put your own
information and pictures into and they
also offer
custom video embedding which i use to
put my youtube videos on my website
and if you are trying to drive traffic
to your online store or your website to
get your name out there
their traffic overview analytics will
help you gain insight into the top
traffic sources
products and other key traffic sources
to help you gain insight on how to drive
more traffic to your website head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
the cosmic wonder to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain
so where is the real sharon again it was
said that she was snapped
so a girl who was already on the run
gets snapped
what happened when she came back well if
this sharing carter is a scroll then the
real sharon carter most likely realized
that her identity had been taken
and she is definitely going to look into
that and she knows nick fury
and has contacts to be able to get in
touch with him and
nick fury has been working with the
skrull since captain marvel so
i wouldn't be surprised if she is
actually working with fury to figure out
why some of the skrull are now
bad and are trying to become powerful
characters on earth and control global
and political happenings
and as i mentioned the mcu is going to
have to lead into
secret invasion because we know that's
coming and i think this could be how it
starts to get set up
and it may just be a coincidence but
secret invasion is about to begin
filming
so the timing for this is kind of spot
on but this is just
my theory what do you think about this
in the comments down below do you think
sharon carter could be a scroll and
possibly be setting up
secret invasion let me know what you
think in the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you